he's getting very emotional because this
is serious yes of course I'm serious oh
my God this is a good one
to kill a male rapist when that male
could just not rape in the first place I
know wouldn't that be great yeah
wouldn't it be [ __ ] great yeah do you
know why wouldn't it be great if men
didn't rape yeah
telling men not to rape isn't gonna make
them not rape you don't think everyone
automatically knows that raping is
against the law like what is he trying
to say he's acting like I don't have a
problem with having the conversation
it's the way they're framing it so I
don't think there's anything wrong with
talking to your son like me talking to
you about what that what that means and
if you ever see a woman in a situation
where it looks like she may be getting
pushed in the direction that she's
uncomfortable with to help her you know
so it we do need to talk about that and
teach men how to be chivalrous and how
to be respectful and how to not cross
but they don't even want gender roles
they don't you can't even teach a woman
you can't even hold the door for a woman
I can hold it for myself we can have
that conversation about making sure that
we're extra sensitive to being gentlemen
especially because uh sexual assault is
is a thing on college campuses and it's
it's an actual thing that happens too
frequently I want to hear about
privileges according to these people
there's all the men in my life work
their ass off nothing
foreign
[Music]
it's the latest installment of change my
mind this time male privilege is a myth
this is going to be fun hey really
quickly I want to hear from you which
subjects would you like to see most
going forward with change my mind we've
done pro-gun pro-life male privilege is
a myth there are two genders comment
below and uh we'll be doing them in the
future we'll get to the unedited segment
interview in a second but one thing that
I want to note is that what these change
my mind segments we can go hours without
a single person sitting down willing to
have a conversation that's the part you
don't see we'll sit down set up and
sometimes it's 30 minutes 45 sometimes
it's several hours and as soon as one
person sits angry left to surround and
feel safe yelling From the Mob all of a
sudden I can't get to everyone fast
enough
got it
great so if you had proof the statistics
of according to the FBI
wait someone just booed right we noted a
boo we noted a boo and we would like to
extend an invitation
I'm really okay
well you can sit down you can sit down
afterwards we'll do it I appreciate it
yeah uh what was that
continue my [ __ ] oh there you go
that's always a sign of an intellectual
Titan
um but you'll you'll get a chance at
that sir now we'll come back to this
gentleman in a minute he's actually the
subject of today's long-form unedited
interview I won't bore you with many
conversations because there wasn't all
that much productive to glean from it if
you look even at our SMU interviews the
one aggressive feminist kind of took
over was confrontational but all of the
others were really productive every
other changed my mind we've ever done
has been pretty productive but I noticed
when discussing the idea of male
privilege or any privilege for that
matter on campus Not only was pretty
much everyone hostile off the bat but
not a single person provided any
substantive argument uh what rights are
afforded in 2018 to men exclusively that
aren't afforded to women
um I feel you're a male privilege
privilege is a myth I feel like because
this is serious yes of course it's
serious white privileged male of course
I chose it of course but I mean the
reason why I chose it then like shapes
other opinions okay my friendly names
within the first two weeks of coming to
the school as a freshman this also might
be why despite having a permit the
gender studies professors who along with
their students teach things he's just an
emotional guy inherently within a system
called the police on us simply for
disagreeing quick bring in the
patriarchy so we weren't really able to
finish our conversations in the first
place and at this point when everything
was anecdotal I kind of just have to
pick one enter this guy the person you
saw before who was yelling and cussing
at me beforehand who also stayed to yell
and cuss at students afterward
raise your hand if you know someone's
been raped on this campus yes yes uh men
have uh physical advantages which oh
Brooks are all of our earlier points
about how why they shouldn't be in
women's sports but if we have plenty of
uh privileges that men don't have I get
to go out to dinner and not pay the bill
and I get to um if you get enough not
carry heavy things if I'm not in the
mood too if you get divorced the man has
to pay you monthly if you get divorced
you automatically get the kid there's
plenty of there's plenty of privileges
that women that women that's that's a
privilege yes not a right but we do
don't women get lighter don't when we
get like lighter sentences for crimes I
don't know all like the whole list of
like statistics and stuff make your own
decisions I'm just sick of him his whole
I'm being stupid too no come up and
debunk my boat talking the whole thing
about rape it's always a great way to
start a civil conversation
what's your name Sarah Gregory Gregory
yeah okay
so why the anger and profanity that was
such a that was such a that was such a
civil conversation let me answer your
question so anger profanity because this
is an extremely sensitive sensitive
topic I just said he's emotional doesn't
think of the logic he thinks with his
feelings
with white with male privilege and I
know you guys the last conversation was
a lot about uh sorry James and you want
to talk about lost but I want to talk
about really about the practicality so
practically you know I I don't I don't
have a car here so sometimes I like to
go down like I go to yoga when I walk
back it's at nights I have my headphones
on I have like a hoodie on so I don't
I'm not aware of my surroundings
an idiot why are you walking alone at
night with your headphone like so first
of all your your hood is up that means
you have limited Vision because your
peripheral vision's blocked off and you
have no sense of sound comfortable doing
that I I didn't I wasn't really
conscientious of that my entire life
until you got a year ago I was on the
phone with my friend and she said she
needed to get her a textbook from her
car and it was like probably 11 30 at
night and she just wouldn't do it
because she didn't feel comfortable she
didn't feel safe sure and so that's
something that's inherent as a male
biologically larger and just like women
that's that's an inherent privilege and
hearing privilege as a male
biological biological my privilege is to
be able to send the man out to the car
so I can just sit here yeah it's true
balance and you can overpower a woman
and for the most part so you believe so
you're saying that male female is by a
lot so given that there was something
out there a lot of these same people
want to be able to limit or take away my
ability to defend my myself and they
want to limit like in Massachusetts it's
so hard to get a concealed carry permit
and I should be able to if I'm if I'm so
weak and I am in danger at all times let
me let's let's level the playing field
why do they make it so hard for people
especially women that who are just oh so
crushed by the patriarchy all day long
biological and and societal and there's
also a systemic
um systemic's going to be where it's
just ingrained in a society okay so so
could you for example explain to me what
the difference would be between a
biological male versus a systemic male
to use your words I did not say there's
a difference between a biological male
systemic well I'm talking about systemic
male privilege and biological okay well
you said you said I'm a biologically men
are bigger and stronger right yes
exactly okay so I just want to make sure
we agree on the premises let me clarify
for you you're biologically males have
privilege because they are larger
because of that they have a certain
safety afforded to them where they can
go out and then they don't have to worry
about you talk yeah
about how males are more vulnerable to
being like to being
um like burglarized or whatever your
thing was no no I didn't that wasn't
what I said okay what did you say
they're more likely to be like
experience violence can I answer
go ahead yeah no they're statistically
more likely to be victims of violent
crime across the board by which gender
now when you just said do you mean
gender biologically or systemically
biological societal and systemic I want
to make sure we're talking about
systemic milk yeah because you're
forgetting the privilege I'm forgetting
the systemic privilege you just said
let's let's assume biological gender is
systemic okay well okay
differences Okay you Okay biological
gender privilege don't forget the
privilege it's been very important yeah
it's very important to remember the
privilege yeah
um okay violent crime many of them would
be committed by Men at Large domestic
violence is very comparable yeah that's
what I'm saying I'm saying domestic
violence would be committed on the same
rate from by a lot the privilege of if
your woman is hitting you if you're it's
a man and woman in a house and the
woman's hitting you you can't like if
you call the cops and you're like this
[ __ ] is crazy she's hitting me they're
not gonna come and like Take The Girl
away I'm gonna take you away no they
take you away but oh my God if she calls
and she's saying oh he's hitting me
which you know obviously men shouldn't
hit women they're coming in blazing
statistically having more being the
victim of violent crime yes
statistically also being the victim of
domestic abuse those victims those men
male victims are mostly being victimized
by other men sure let's go with that
yeah sure you think everyone's not lazy
no I didn't say it's unlikely let's go
without people okay you can all agree on
on that yeah and then so so for women
they don't have that biologically we're
still on the biological part right when
they're a lot when they're smaller when
they can be overpowered more easily they
they can they don't have the same
privilege when they can't go running by
themselves
cussing at me so I'm going to finish my
sentence and if you want to listen
that'd be great if you don't you don't
have to what I'm talking about here is
privilege I do not see it as a privilege
having a violent crime committed against
you at a multiple rate likelihood is
committed by a male but the man who is
getting violently assaulted I do not
believe is more privilege than the woman
who isn't and statistically that's the
likelihood it's not a privilege because
biologically that male who's being
assaulted by another male has a better
chance of Defending themselves than a
female who is being assaulted by a male
and that's the gender difference we're
going to talk about male privilege sure
you have to talk about the influence on
the opposite gender don't I don't I
don't give a [ __ ] about you when you're
talking about like male and male crime
really I do this is not what it's about
if you want to talk about that sure talk
about talk about crime let's talk about
crime when you're talking about male
privilege yes you know like Don lemon's
point about how black lives matter isn't
about all black lives inherent
differences between the genders I agree
on I agree that biology determines sex
and gender yeah are less likely and less
capable of Defending themselves against
the opposite gender sure biological all
right no listen I agree that's why I'm a
huge supporter of women concealing and
carrying okay that's a completely
different subject no it's not it's not
at all
I don't want women as you're trying to
set the premise as though for some
reason women are less likely tonight
two seconds this is not about male and
males crime and this is not about access
to the Firearms right now I want to talk
about the Practical different the
Practical livelihood uh or existence of
white we want to talk about systemic
privilege
to be stronger overall than women that
is true we go right to a solution level
the playing field make sure that
concealed carry is an option for all
Americans and if a man who's a creep
sees a woman walking down the street and
he doesn't know that she that she might
she might be carrying even carry like
pepper sprays it was about 18. okay I'm
going to speak now and I'm not going to
Custard in the Discord so the point is
uh we are talking about systemic
privilege no one at any point I am still
open to anyone can sit down has given me
any example of a right afforded to a man
unafforded to a woman that's what we're
really talking about systemic privilege
now we've just acknowledged both of us
that men are statistically much more
likely to be the victim of a violent
crime we're statistically much more
likely to die at the workplace okay now
this is something that matters to me and
perhaps not to you and then that's okay
we can disagree I don't believe that the
man who is 70 80 more likely to have a
violent crime committed against him is
privilege whether it's committed by
another man or not now I would agree
maybe we could find common ground and
hear what I'm talking about is I don't
want to see women victimized as a matter
of fact most men don't and the only way
a woman would be able to defend herself
against a violent crime though
statistically far less likely than that
of it occurring with a man would be a
mechanical advantage in a firearm would
you not agree yeah sure it's sure yeah
but this is not about guns no it is no
it's about protecting women and it's
about keeping women from being
victimized okay cool that's that's just
that's what men have also but you want
to talk about male privilege so we're
talking about differences between the
genders you want to talk about Firearms
real quick let's end that conversation
with this age we don't have a different
accessibility to Firearms look at the
thing is that there is
the thing is that there is a male
privilege like yes it is a privilege
that you're stronger but then there's
also female privilege and there's
disadvantages like everyone and
everything there's like a privilege and
a disadvantage to everything you know
what I mean yes so let's get past this
male privilege of um a physical strength
because this is the only one that the
only aspect of male privilege that this
particular food fellow can come up with
he cannot there's nothing else here
exactly that's a great thing and their
privileges there you go there's there's
no privilege there what I'm talking
about is wanting to have fewer let me
let me boil it down in a way that maybe
might be reductive I would like to read
far more headlines okay that say rapist
shot dead in a ditch why a woman with a
38 special than woman raped on campus
because of some concealed carry law okay
so I don't want female victims that have
nothing to do with rapists I would
exactly you know why do why how do you
stop why do you have to rape is a woman
to kill a male rapist when that male
could just not rape in the first place I
know wouldn't that be great yeah yeah
who are you arguing with you're Don
coyote fighting windmills man
we all agree rape is bad you think I'm
here
away with it no they get away without
this [ __ ] campus really yes
they [ __ ] do okay give me names
within the first two weeks of coming to
the school as a freshman she was a
[ __ ] virgin too Milton Daniel Hall
you know what that [ __ ] got to
do he had to move out of that Hall but
he had to move out that's about it
really yeah so this so this was a rape
so you're getting very emotional because
this is seriously not of brushing it
under that brushing it under the rug and
um not actually investigating enough and
not punishing that that that's just true
oh I can go in there I can stay on my my
little bubble of TCU I don't have to
turn my back I don't have to worry about
my job my my income or anything like
that I don't have to worry about getting
raped well you should my friends you
should worry you should worry about
yourself you should worry about
communication
you should worry about you should worry
about communicating with adults you
should worry about treating other
people's respect because this will
affect your future employment
opportunities if you first came in here
and talked about how you put on your
hoodie your headphones you don't even
look around in the periphery that's dumb
that's stupid you should worry about
your safety yeah that's not that's
fundamentally unintelligent white black
yellow red I don't care it's not smart
to do it's also not smart to come in and
say we should get men to stop raping us
I'm not your father I'm not your father
but you come in here so you're going to
school somebody and cuss and yell and
say you need to stop rapist everyone
here wants to stop rapist everyone here
wants to stop rapists okay the point is
this kind of double speak and this kind
of rhetoric and this these kinds of
false platitudes help women you know
what you're doing you're victimizing
actual victims of rape there is no one
in five rape statistic when you say men
get away with it we allow men to get off
scot-free with rape it's not true and
you absolve people with personal
responsibility it leads to the worst
Society leads to a polarized campus it
leads to God forbid actual rape cultures
like we see across the Islamic culture
in this campus is there what is Reaper
okay what is the rape culture this is
the real culture on TCU is is brewed up
by first of all twice having twice as
many women have twice the money it
creates a different social Dynamic Greek
life so how do you change it let me
continue let me continue that first
example my friend who was raped within
their first two weeks apology here uh oh
don't tell me she went to a frat party
because you know how I feel about
[ __ ] frat guys don't even get me
started don't tell me you got blackout
drunk and then your dumb drunk friends
left you there having lost your resume
to rape it's terrible woman the the
criminal who's on charge was does he
have a name pledge I'm not I'm not gonna
release this will go to a lot of people
it's not my decision she did not want to
release his name she did she doesn't
want this to be a public thing okay
don't judge her for that so don't roll
yourself just look at his face no no no
no no no I am making you I am judging
okay not her I'm making it I'm judging
the decision you're judging her victim
so I'm judging the decision that's a bad
decision because you know what that guy
could go forward and rape another woman
so this stupid false victim status I
don't want that guy
how do we stop a rapist if we can't
charge him or get anything do they tell
do they do they make it okay so this
wait go ahead sorry there you go no
there's more context coming in out
coming out now so he's complaining that
the only thing that happened is the guy
who moved out of the dorms but now she's
saying that am I catching this right
that the she chose not to press charges
so how are you going to have a case if
she won't press charges so so what does
he want to happen then what is it was
supposed to be some magic fairy that
takes him I was gonna say he he doesn't
want like her name and stuff to get out
there but like I'm pretty sure if you go
to like the police or something like
they don't if they go in the news and
they talk about like the rape or
whatever it's not like he re someone
raped this girl this is where she lives
this is where she goes to school this is
her name like no but it does it you know
that word sprouts like wildfire on
campus so if she made it a bigger issue
it would have she would have been
everywhere she probably would have
wanted to leave campus and just get out
of there depending on the sizes how do
we start
stopping a racist would be to put him in
jail do you have to have the punishment
for rape to be so significant not just
taken away swimming scholarship and
attendance at Stanford for that for that
rapist but at this school she didn't
want to put out the name and make it a
public thing because she did not want to
be associated with directly this is a
small school she puts out his name her
name gets out there she doesn't want
that she doesn't want to be known as a
victim that is true the school knows you
did want to prevent other that that same
person or his Affiliates from raping a
gun because she told the school okay so
the school and police have his name and
there was a correct he was and he was
charged he was no no he was moved out of
because she because he lived in the same
Hall as her Milton Den he had to move
out of the hall both freshmen see each
other for the rest so the police were
given a name of a man who forcibly raped
a woman and you're telling me they just
removed him from the hall this is the
story when it comes to criminal when it
comes to conviction are there other
things that are needed proof yes uh
exceptional things and and is a big one
Christopher Collette well that dude
needs to support that girl that got
raped many to step up and put Knuckles
to the rapist facts whoa logic logic and
facts and you know what if she had real
men for friends that guy would have
every [ __ ] bone in his face and his
body broken will we not agree on that
yeah obviously proof is important
obviously okay and so when it comes to
the the practicalness of this event it
is uh let me talk because we talked
about the culture so I'm talking I going
back to the example because those they
were Greek they were pledges of rapists
okay and you want to know what his
brothers did when they found out about
this I'm guessing something bad correct
yeah
um they do not go up to her and
apologize and say you know he's a bad
egg so-and-so Greek fraternity entered
Greek words um does not back this we do
not represent this no they they harassed
her they said do not ruin this kid's
life for one dumb mistake he was
intoxicated he was this he wasn't
thinking sure he thought you were cute
okay that's what they did and that's why
stomach I was a part of a fraternity
here I left because two members were put
on our version of our internal Supreme
Court they were given chance at their
chance at the chance they were put they
were in they were in positions of power
within the TCU Community to where they
were subject to this dude's not wrong to
an extent like he's just really
emotional but like yeah like frat guys
and [ __ ] like there are a lot of them
are creepy and they do weird stuff and
they do get away with a lot it's true so
it's true we're not even really
disagreeing there just needs to be like
a better solution this dude's just a
crybaby and he doesn't know how to have
a real conversation incoming freshman
they were subject to other girls and
they they used that power in ways where
they ended up harassing these girls
sexually assaulting these girls that's
terrible within the fraternity they were
given chance at the chance at their
chance until they just became maybe
inactive can I or they just did not they
were not big enough they were not a part
of the fraternity enough to be to where
they would shed Badness and that's why I
left can I ask a question correct okay
because you went you kind of I think we
both acknowledge you jumped from a few
topics there so I'd like to kind of
donate a couple and then hopefully we
can move forward
so you mentioned that this man uh raped
her uh the school knew about it the
police knew about it he was simply moved
to another uh house to Simply move to
another dorm then you said that the
Greek House knew about it and basically
was encouraging and they harassed her
right okay do you have any proof uh
eyewitness account of course
um and that's that's probably one of the
reasons why I was in Lincoln there was
no there was no GoPros everywhere you
know there was that's that's how it
happens thanks Mitchell that's how it
happened we just said yeah any proof you
just you just gave this whole example to
paint a picture of white male privilege
on campus and this rape culture
any proof and
proof proof I believe her and okay and
there was you know she lost to Virginia
there was there was their stains
I'm sure if she wanted to call the FBI
made it make a big deal I'd have her
name and face painting everywhere I'm
sure okay if there isn't the existence
of DNA proof okay so here's my point
we'd have to we have to find some common
ground in our grand supremacies here so
no proof there that you would be able to
present that anyone is presented you may
be going to the direction of assuming
that she wasn't raped and I would
strongly advise you don't follow you oh
I'll take it under advisement
um but uh I do have proof because that
is proof that there is not a rape
culture on campus because there there is
a chance that she wasn't raped and I
hate to say that because God if you know
that's hurtful to somebody that was you
know if she was but this is where we
have innocent until proven guilty and
this is why you go to the legal system
and have the conversation you know and
really bring out all the evidence yeah
no yeah the statistic is not a one in
five rape corner of the FBI it's one in
over 1800 there's not a rape culture on
campus in the United States these rapes
do not occur without consequence when
there is proof presented the constant is
not men getting away with rape I'm
certainly not convinced of that I'm not
convinced by your account it sounds like
a harrowing account I feel horrible that
that had occurred so you think you think
I feel good about that I don't think my
point is I say don't give a [ __ ] ing
well then listen you can describe mode
of all you want but I do have virtual to
get some laughs from some people I know
a case where a woman got raped she
reported it her husband got a few
friends together and now a rape case has
become a murder case husband is now on
doing time and she's alone with the kids
well that's not what we're saying is
that's crazy that's crazy but other
people down yeah
the only person who's insulted anyone
all day here all day is you you came in
cussing and yelling and swearing no
because I'm pissed I get it serious I
get it serious just because you feel
pissed doesn't mean that you should go
and start acting off your emotions and
yelling at people yeah this is a simple
thing about being a man that they don't
even want to teach you anymore act on
your emotions
rape culture and you have a proof of
that you say you don't I do have proof
and there is no rape if you're a girl
you don't got to go out you don't want
to put out that hey I was raped you
don't want to do that you don't want to
be raped if you're a girl obviously we
were talking about the statistics no but
you said you don't wanna you don't want
to go for one in five percent yeah there
is no rape culture in the United States
campus I don't I don't I don't I don't
agree and the statistics don't reflect
that so if you had proof the statistics
of according to the FBI
and 12 percent of men are raped on
college campuses incorrect
[Music]
12 did you say 12 of women are raped on
college campus to 12 of men back up go
ahead let's listen to what she said well
because I couldn't really wear it
the statistics of according to the FBI
said are raped on college campuses
incorrect
[Music]
I would love for you to come and sit
down when you have the microphone and I
would love to talk about that with you
now you see this is why this is not me
being rude same thing I gave a Chantelle
so you know what I just noticed is that
we [ __ ] leaned into the computer like
it'd make us hear better
yeah oh my God that's like when I'm
driving and I go over the bus I go over
the radio to focus
Chantel Chanel sorry sorry Chanel I
apologize see she's not gonna give me go
for she sees it was an easy mistake I
wanted her to have her opportunity to
speak I don't necessarily agree with her
but I would say it was very respectful
you were cussing yelling coming in a
little a little bit emotional and I want
you to have your opportunity to speak as
well and so it's disrespectful for her
to yell out we're having a conversation
I disagree this is not about cement it's
not about being like we're not in a
parliamentary system we're not allowed
to interrupt and [ __ ] like that this is
important you're actually allowed to
interrupt in a parliamentary system
you're talking to someone who comes from
Canada parliamentary
appreciate it man thank you there you go
thank you I wouldn't even shake a hand
hey did you enjoy this video
[Music]